this is a production of cornell
university
hi thank you harold for that
introduction i'm fabia as mentioned
this is my fifth year here and i'm
wrapping up this project hopefully in
the next few months uh in defending so
it's not all my work uh obviously
there's little bits and pieces that are
still uh need to be done
and i'm sure you'll get a chance to see
that later but i wanted to present on
what i have and just kind of the overall
uh path of my phd so
um
i'm going to talk about improving soil
health in bihar specifically
and
okay yes excellent
sorry uh as an introduction i know we
all come from very very diverse
backgrounds so kind of break down my
title
uh i talked about soil health so kind of
what is that it's
looking at the physical chemical and
biological properties of soil
and you're basically trying to
look at soil functionality
and see how it sustains
not just plants as in agriculture but
also other functions like regulating
water
and if that's kind of a broad concept or
if it seems vague that's
kind of the truth uh what we're really
trying to do
is um
i think there's a pointer somewhere here
but yes so what you have is little
services from you know agricultural food
production water quality
and what you're trying to do is find a
way to see how soil affects those
services and you'll have your functions
what you're trying to do is estimate
some of these processes and what we're
doing is picking properties that we're
like
these are the indicators that we think
encompass soil health um the physical
and the biological and those chemical
characteristics
so i'll talk a little about the
indicators that i've picked when i come
to methodology
and we'll discuss that a little more
then
why is soil health important why am i
even talking about it
in south asia especially you have a lot
of degraded soils
it's also almost all land that can be
under agricultural production is
so you have if you want to increase
productivity it has to come from
increasing yield and land that's already
under agriculture
and the reason we want to do this is
because we have shown that increases in
soil quality or soil health and i might
use these to interchangeably can improve
yields so
that's good that's what we want to try
to do in bihar
uh before i get into why we are just a
little context and background for indian
cropping systems for those who don't
know
we have the wet season the karif which
is when we're going to talk growing rice
that's where we talk about and the ravi
cropping season which is the dry season
where we often grow wheat and there's
sometimes a shorter season in the middle
uh but none of this
where you can enter crop well
not the main system that i'm looking at
here
and the area that i'm focused is the
indo-gangetic plane so this is just for
india though it does extend into
pakistan and bangladesh as well
and what you're seeing here is i don't
know how clear this is but you have the
different cropping systems off the
country
and the very purple area here that you
can see is rice wheat systems so that's
why we're looking at rice through
systems it is the primary uh cropping
system in the area
this specific area accounts for 85
off all rice reproduction in south asia
so
it's obviously a very important
location
for this system
uh and the reason we're picking bihar is
because of the state almost 70 percent
of that cropped area is in rice meat
systems
but the agricultural productivity in the
state is well below the national average
especially compared to the western part
of the indo-gangetic plane
it's also important from a social
economic perspective because it has a
population of almost 100 million and
close to 80 of that is involved in
agriculture so
very very important to the economy of
the states
and
final background as i get into this is
why rice wheat systems
i mean i kind of mentioned this earlier
it is the predominant system in the area
um and is as cereal crops is very
important to the country as a whole
but the reason we're also concerned
about it is because just these
continuous rice wheat systems can lead
to severe decline and quality and these
have been in production for decades at
this point
and you are seeing some of the effects
and other environmental effects whether
it's also soil organic matter or
nutrient imbalances
another big concern is that rice in
these areas is puddled and transplanted
so um there are obviously reasons to do
that in preventing wheat growth
and usually improving nutrient
availability but there's also huge
concerns with that especially when it
comes to soil physical structure and
soil compaction as well as methane
production
and another reason um that this is
getting kind of important and is that
there is evidence that yields are either
stagnating or declining
uh and
there's
uh some discussion on if that's just
because of you know lack of like a
mismanagement or if that's the soil and
we're trying to get into like what are
some of the reasons that could be
uh broad project outlines
the first uh two chapters that i'm going
to talk about and that's going to be
predominantly this presentation is
looking at long-term trials in this area
and
this all thanks to the great
collaborations that we have in the state
with the serial systems of south asia
um the local university which is the
rajasthan central agricultural
university and the borlaug institute of
south asia so these institutions have
been managing uh various write speed uh
trials for
some start as like very early in the 90s
so
they've been doing this for many years
now and we're trying to see
what the effect is of these long-term
systems
and we're kind of off the six
experiments that i'll look at i've kind
of broken them down into two
chapters and the way i'm kind of looking
at this is first
looking at some of the common management
techniques that have been suggested to
reduce those environmental impacts and
that's residue addition and tillage
reduction
so
like i kind of mentioned before these
systems are intensively tilled they're
puddles and also most of this residue is
removed from the field so
um like resources have long suggested
obviously there's zero till and residue
edition might improve that soil uh
health might increase yields
and what we're trying to do is just
quantify some of those long-term effects
of these practices
on the soil
the second chapter is looking at crop
diversification so maybe the answer is
that rice feed you're not going to get
you know much better yields so
what are things we can do whether that's
inter-cropping or changing the rotation
that can improve soil health and
increase profits for farmers
um also things like you know changing
climates and
you know more water scarcity
there's
you know we're trying to see basically
uh are there other crop systems that
could improve or replace these rice
wheat systems
and the third chapter which i'm not
going to talk too much in detail about
is looking at some of that spatial
variation of soil properties
and this is again with the help of
serious assistance initiative of south
asia as those environmental defense fund
uh and what we're trying to do is model
some of those linkages between yield
soil health and management
and the way i'm doing that is we have
soil samples collected from
actually the 400 sites are over 4 000
sites actually across bihar and of those
about 400 have been analyzed by me for
the entire
soil health indicators and i also have
management and yield data so um that's
what i'm going to work that's what i'm
currently working on but i'm not going
to present much data from that today
all right uh getting into methodology so
again i know we all come from diverse
backgrounds i won't get into too much
detail here but i can tell you that the
very first thing i had to do as part of
my phd project was set up the lab um
soil samples cannot be shipped from
india to the us so i can't just you know
collect the samples put them in a bag
and ship them here where i can do them
in the comfort of bradfield
uh so i had to set up the lab in india
um there are
some issues with that and we're going to
talk
kind of professing some of the reasons
we may not see the same you know
variation in indicators that we see in
the us is because the labs are not
climate controlled
so trying to keep a consistent
temperature for some of these indicate
like some of these analyses have been
very hard
um
we
like i sourced a lot of the equipment
that we needed for the analyses some we
had to like navigate exactly how to do
it in these universities so
that was a nice long fun and frustrating
process
but the indicators that we're trying to
look at are the comprehensive assessment
of oil health and that was developed at
cornell
um
the reason that these indicators were
picked are of course you know the
relevance to the soil properties that we
talked about
they're consistent they're reproducible
and they're easy and low cost to do
which is obviously you know they might
be very precise indicators but if you
have to spend a whole lot of money doing
it that may not be the best
use of our time for a long large scale
project
and
i picked this again because there's a
lot of data that's been done in the us
that i had access to so it's a nice
comparison
um and because
all of these reasons it's just it covers
all assault biological physical and
chemical processes
and they are actually reproducible and
easy to do in india
uh for physical we're looking at the
available water capacity uh penetration
resistance for surface and subsurface
which we do in fields and aggregate
stability
for the biological um i'm looking at
organic carbon actually it's organic
matter um there's a little protein
respiration and active carbon which is
for magnetic oxidizable carbon
and for the chemical indicators i'm
looking at a number of micronutrients
soil ph and potassium and phosphorus
i'm not going to go into too much detail
about the methodology but um here's
basically
how for the processes for each indicator
just briefly whether that's penetrometer
a rapid soul texture
um
for respiration and epoxy
for some of the chemical indicators i
won't present a lot of the chemical
indicators today
mostly because you don't see a lot of
differences a lot of most of these
long-term thoughts are fertilized
so you're not releasing any
micronutrient deficiencies in any of
these systems
but
where these were done by the university
lab um pulling you know standard
methodology that they've used for many
years
and finally uh i present some of the raw
data but what i'll also present is the
soil health index so this again has been
done for the u.s um
oh you know using thousands and
thousands of samples but it's basically
you're constructing a population of all
the data that you have
um to create a normal distribution right
so that's you know your low farmer your
farmers that have maybe you know uh
poorer soils
really well managed soils and your kind
of normally distributed farmers in the
middle
uh and you're taking that to a
cumulative normal distribution function
so this is just to kind of make it an
easier score from zero to 100 uh so
you're not telling a farmer well you
have 400 ppm of probiotic oxidizable
carbon which is obviously
incomprehensible
uh to the farmer that you're trying to
explain this to
one of the things this is going to be
kind of a sneak peek into one of my
conclusions
a lot of previous research has shown
that this is that this does vary by
region right so if you're just taking
the entire population what you're going
to find is that some regions are
inherently lower um and
that's going to be a problem
and so
like like we'll discuss maybe a little
later
what i have done is only use the
populations for my indian data because
what i did find in my initial
experiment like in my initial analysis
if i try use
the
cache
indicator like the cash formula that's
been created in the u.s
all the indicators will come out very
very low um and that's just because of
the nature of these tropical soils
so
what i've used is done the same
methodology but for the biological and
physical indicators
based off my data sampled in india
so when i report a soil health index
that's what it's based off
and just again kind of calculating like
i mentioned uh for most indicators
you're using this
uh cumulative normal distribution of
like low to high
for some especially so this is
specifically for penetrometer and
surface surface and subsurface hardness
higher is actually worse because
obviously the ground is very hard you
have a high
like surface hardness and that's
like not good so what you're doing is
the other way around
and for some indicators though i uh i
haven't done some of the chemical
analyses uh yet
is like ph where you want a medium
all right so
diving into chapter one
this is an experiment established in
1988 so it's been going on for
quite a few decades now and what i'm
looking at in the first few chapters
like i said is the addition of residue
and tillage
and trying to determine the effect of
these
so this is like a very nice clear
experiment you have
zero to 100 percent of crop residue
incorporation um zinc was also applied
once to these plots just because zinc
deficiency is a huge issue in the area
what we do find is that biological
properties improve with addition of
residues so
and very clear 0-100 linear what you're
seeing is protein for magneto-accessible
carbon and organic carbon
um all improve with the addition of
residue
respiration is actually rarely um
significant in most of my plots again
because it's the most temperature
dependent
so
while you might see trends the
variability is often just too high to
get any statistical significance
uh you do also see
penetrometer this is surface hardness
because these are so intensively tilled
that there's just a power pan
at about 15 centimeters so you cannot
get any subsurface hardness values for
this
um but for surface hardness you do see
uh improvement oh i need to go back
did i go
yes
uh you do see improvements with the
addition of residue
the second experiment that we're looking
at again first three are all rice wheat
and this is the addition of various
organic amendments this is
either the addition of promoter manure
proper residue or proper residue and
pharmaceutical
um
i think i may start putting a little uh
how much but it's about 10 kilograms of
farm air manure
and what we see is that here while there
are um trends upwards with addition of
organic amendments
you're not seeing the same statistical
significance so you are seeing
the trend of the green bar which is prop
residue and farmyard manure
is clearly doing a lot better than the
no manure plots but um just we see less
significance and it's presumably because
it's very tiny many thoughts we have for
these university trials
uh what we do see significance is the
aggregate stability here which does
improve with the addition of both uh
residue and farmyard manure
uh and you can see here again just
powering manure is not really having
much of an effect but proper residue
also does
improve this lightly
okay
so i'm going to talk a little about the
yields data that i have
that i've been able to analyze so far
so what we do see is with rice and wheat
yields and total is just the addition of
them
the two of them
we do see
like none of these yields are
significant but what you'll see in some
of the others is that wheat yields
fields
does show some slight effect if you can
uh kind of take a look here so there is
some
light correlation in this plot again
because of the small plot size but in
some of the others you'll see a little
better correlation
okay uh and
time the final experiment of this
chapter
is um the
like you have eight trials up over here
this one gets very complicated so i'm
gonna try to slow down and break it up a
little
the experiment is looking at various
systems so it looks at the puddle
transplanted conventional rice and
conventionally filled wheat
um it tries to kind of break it down
from like zero tills rice and
conventionally tills wheat and then you
know conventionally tilled rice and zero
told wheat it tries out a treatment of
like non-bottle transplanted rice
and the additions of residue or not
or a permanent bed and residue
it's set up as you know looking at these
different systems so it's not a very
clear factorial um experiment that's not
the that was the purpose of this
experiment so i cannot look at the
um
uh i cannot look at residue and tillage
together i can't look at their
interaction just because of the way
these thoughts are set up
there's no
treatment that's
conventionally tilled and has
residue
so that's just the way these systems
were set up but what i have look at is
the addition of residue separately and
the addition of tillage separately so
i've kind of broken this down so you're
not seeing eight into twenty like four
bars of very large graphs i have that in
the back if anyone is very curious at
the end but
um i'm gonna try to make this simple for
most of the other audience
over here i'm looking at just residue
and so i have like your conventionally
tails rice and wheat and i look at the
three
uh residue editions that we have
and what we do see is that um
whether it's just crop residue or
whether it's a brain manure which is
just asbania that's added to the flood
and then killed
we are seeing improvements
the one thing we don't really see an
improvement in is a permanent bed um and
whether that's just because of you know
um issues with the bed being in the
especially in the wet season um
having an issue like not being formed
properly
or something else which i'm still
looking into
permanent bed we don't actually see any
improvements compared to the
conventionally tilled
when it comes to
sorry when it comes again to soil
physical properties we see aggregate
stability doing again better with the
addition of residue
in here um surface hardness decreases
with the permanent bed but again because
it's a permanent bed that's a little
uh tricky to get the um that data is
uh bound to be different just because it
is a permanent bed but we don't see that
much other difference with the addition
of residue versus the puddles and
conventionally told
so kind of separating out whether it's
tillage so again i'm looking at you know
intensely tilled final transplanted
conventional filled wheat
which is the one we're always going to
compare things to
um we have your medium tillage where at
least one of the treatments is non uh
zero till
um
i also have the non-puddle transplanted
rice here just because it um
it is like lightly tilled but it is not
puddled
um and then we have the zero tillage
and what we find again with tillage is
that there is a small effect and it's
primarily off the unpuddled uh
conventionally tilled rice
so one of the things that's curious
about this is it might actually
this is the only time where we separate
the puddling and the tillage so
what you might actually see is that
puddling is having a stronger effect
like if we stop
reducing puddling
um actually might improve some of these
indicators
and when it comes to soil physical
health uh we are seeing that reducing
tillage in any kind of form uh generally
reduces surface hardness compared to the
conventionally tilled
um and often like increases aggregate
stability
and here again
we're seeing that there's no
significant correlation of rice
but we do see a significant correlation
of wheat and preliminary results suggest
that's
generally true across the various
experiments with wheat we are seeing
stronger correlations and even a
stronger effect of
soil health
with rice probably because it's the wet
season many of these treatments are
puddled
we're not really seeing the effect of
that we're like soil health isn't really
strongly correlated to rice fields
specifically
right so that's kind of the end of the
first chapter and i spoke about this a
little but what we are seeing is that
that addition of crop residue is mostly
increasing biological properties
whereas tillage um has a stronger effect
on physical properties and affects the
biological properties less
and preliminary results suggest that
wheat yield is correlated to soil health
index but not the rice yield
okay i said i should reach the end or
not
uh
let's jump to chapter two
here like i said i'm looking at crop
diversification especially compared to
rice wheat systems
so here again
this is set up as studying various
different systems you have
your conventionally tilled rice and
wheat and the third season is left
fallow it's what a lot of farmers tend
to do in the area
with scenario two we're adding moon bean
which is a legume to the system and with
scenario three
it's actually the same except here we're
zero tilling
all three crops
and with the last we're adding we're
removing wheat actually and adding
mustard and spring means
and we're finding is that the addition
of legume specifically seems to improve
the soil biological properties
uh especially the permanganate
oxidizable carbon you can see the yellow
and the blue are both the
treatments with legumes they're both
higher
and
with organic carbon
just diversifying out of rice wheat it
has a little bit of organic carbon to it
so this is on the secondary axis here
but they're not statistically
significant
okay
um over here it's a little hard to
separate out tillage and crop rotation
because obviously
we're seeing
these given these are systems it's not a
very clear again factorial addition and
non-addition of crop and tillage
but what we do see is again
diversifying out of the conventional
does seem to improve soil penetration
here especially
subsurface hardness
and these are the final two experiments
that i want to talk about
this again is a fairly large experiment
with eight treatments i'm not gonna
go into all of them
um what i have can tell you what i did
is uh
average out the rice wheat systems and
compare it to the various different crop
rotations that we try out here one which
is maize wheat
soybean wheat maize chickpea
soybean winter maize and maize mustard
so
um this is just
various different scenarios of crops
that have been grown in the area and can
be like proposed as alternative
solutions
uh and what we find is that
they're not necessarily like better or
worse um there's really no statistical
difference
there's slight improvements of some
indicators uh with a crop a cropping
system versus the other but it's not
consistent either so
um it's not like you can say that like
maize mustard is one that tends to do a
little better
um
soybean winter maize sometimes
maize wheat can go from like being
a high protein indicator but a low per
magnetic oxidizable carbon so
the data doesn't really tell you much as
it is so um
trying to break that down even further
because we did say that legume addition
in the previous experiment seemed to do
better this isn't the same legume this
is chickpea uh what we're seeing is that
it doesn't really have in fact again
none of these are statistically
significant
um with organic carbon actually some
fizzing stomachs go down
um but again yeah not significant so
we're not really seeing any of that
effect yet
and i come to my conclusions i'll talk
about maybe why that is
um looking at the physical properties
again no statistical significance even
though this is like a fairly large
treatment um
and again if you average out rice sweets
you're not really seeing
much of a difference here
like surface or subsurface hardness
when it comes to legume there's a slight
difference here
i realize that that should have also
popped up on the other one but that's
my mistake but uh what we are seeing is
that aggregate stability just adding the
legume improves it again a little
but
uh it's not a very large effect again
and um let me talk actually about the
why maybe because before i jump to the
conclusion
one of the things that i'm trying to
look at now is the amount of biomass
that's returned back to the soil so
one of the things that we're
hypothesizing is it's not necessarily
the specific cropping system that you
pick it's
how much uh plano biomass does that crop
produce
whether that's below ground whether it's
background because all of these systems
you do have crop residue being added
back to it
so um the differences that we see might
not necessarily be you know diversifying
out of rice wheat will always be
beneficial but specific systems because
the amount of biomass they produce might
actually show benefits
and
i'll discuss that maybe a little more of
the conclusions as well but i wanted to
mention that here as well
and the final experiment that we look at
is rice knees
and this is just i'm sorry yeah this is
just rice meat so we can't really
compare it to a rice wheat system at
least within this treatment
but the thing we're interested in is
rice mace which has often been proposed
as an alternative and is often grown in
the area
how like water been like you know
management effects that could be done
here whether that's addition of residue
or zero till
uh and what we find is that um
again this is
with the addition
of residue and a reduction of tillage um
it's not that much difference maize
seems to do quite well
for itself especially if the rice may
system doesn't see much effect the
conventional is actually
higher organic carbon than any of the
others
and
i'm still working on some of the
physical properties i'm not presenting
that right now
but kind of coming back to the
conclusions that i talked about
there's not a very strong effect of crop
diversity right so it or if there is
it's not obvious yet so that's some of
the things we're still trying to tease
out
um like specific cropping systems like
inclusion of like you might benefit soil
health
but what legume that is might also
vary so
one of the like you know stronger
hypotheses that i have is that soil
health might just depend on that amount
of production
and residue application so
depending on the crop you pick
and it's about below ground biomass that
might actually be the um
key that's it like you know affecting
soil health
yeah i actually sped through really fast
um
because we're almost coming to the end
but let's talk a little about my chapter
three like i said this is data that i'm
still working on so i don't want to
present
uh data that's too preliminary but i do
want to talk about the project itself
and what i'm trying to do is study these
relationships between yields management
and soil health
uh the way we did that is um sai but
relational assistance initiative in
south asia uh surveyed over four
thousand farmers during the rice speed
season
and collected data from management to
yields
soil samples were collected from each of
these fields at one point of time
and chemical analyses of all these soil
samples were run in like three different
labs in bihar
what i did is subset about 500 of those
samples and run the biological and
physical properties
of these soils
and what i'm currently working on is
modeling the relationship between soil
health the yield that we have reported
and the management data that we have and
then seeing if they're spatially diverse
across
oh well
especially diverse across the states
i only have data from a few districts
right now so that's obviously one of the
key limitations with this
but we are seeing just preliminarily is
that there are differences across
districts
whether that's any
specific spatial
difference that we're going to see is
something that i'm still working on but
what we are seeing is um there's some
difference among districts
and uh first steps like i talked about
is
presenting some of the modeling work
between yields low health and management
determining if there is racial variation
across districts
examine the effects of biomass additions
um and then finally this is the thing i
spoke about developing a regional soil
health index
um so the ones that i've presented
currently are the biological and
physical properties so
expanding that to include the chemical
properties that we have
and
fine-tuning it so that we can actually
use this for areas around indium
and i have spread through this fast okay
so final conclusions
uh one just uh going back to the need
for a regional index
the values of indicators are a lot lower
in india than the u.s
that's why we can't just use the cash
yeah we can't just use the cash values
that we would get from the us formula in
india
kind of reinforcing again reducing
tillage mitigate that effective muddling
it appears and residue addition improved
soil health especially the biological
properties
diversifying out of high speed systems
needs to be studied further
and we are seeing that wheat yield is
showing some correlation but rye seal is
not sensitive to soil health
okay um that's plenty of time for
questions but i just wanted to
acknowledge all the amazing people who i
couldn't have done this without
obviously harold and my community andrew
and prabhu
um all the people who gave me so much
support from my lab
to sonam who was at colonel and is now
working
for simmet uh zach bob
um all the collaborators in india all
the professors
and heads of the institutions have been
working with me
just just some of the people but all
these amazing folks from family and
friends
all right
thank you
i should uh
add that
kobe's pac research was uh was
disproportionately impacted by the covet
pandemic because
she was prevented from going to india
and
complete all the soil health analyses so
sometimes it really
had a greater impact than most of us
were
there was a speed run of 200 samples in
like six weeks
questions
i just have a question about the details
on the residue incorporation uh-huh yes
i'm wondering is is the residue
chopped or cut in some way or is it just
the whole plant residue
incorporated and then in addition to
that i was wondering when it's
incorporated does all of the residue get
buried or at least under the soil
surface or is some of it still sitting
on the top of the sulfur
so it varies across the different
experiments because each of the
institutions manage it slightly
differently
some kind of incorporated in uh when
like if they're tilling and they're
doing residue they might just
incorporate in that way
some it's just left on the surface so
kind of varies there's not a consistency
with that and there's no chopping or
cutting except for the maybe the
yeah um no as far as i know there's no
extra chopping or cutting yeah
thank you
peter and then you're honest
um
a good good presentation for a very very
difficult project uh you know you should
be congratulated in being able to get
the results you have
thank you it's always struck me and you
know i was involved
yeah
you started many of these yeah five
years so
one of the things i always had problems
with is
that one of the advantages of nova till
is that you plant earlier and closer to
the optimum time right and one of the
biggest benefits of motel
on yield was because you have the proper
timing when you do land preparation you
take a long time to probably land
late and then you get zapped at the end
of the season through
hot weather
um
i know that probably the daily you're
collecting stuff from your experiments
right
sorry you're not collecting these this
data from you're collecting the data but
you're not involved in managing no no
i'm not managing any of these products
that's really difficult yeah because i
kept telling people you really need to
plant the no tour plus
early
and then the till plus later on right
then
right and i mean that's one of the
things that i'm curious about seeing
because i know previous research was
from planting date is so important um
and i'm hoping to see some of that uh in
when i'm modeling across farmer fields
because i do have some of that
information
but yeah that's the issue again with
some of these long-term plots especially
like with the university being decades
old that's you know that's great in
terms of like long-term uh looking at
long-term effects but there's
possibilities of that management
changing across time and the current
folks just aren't even aware that that
happened so
um because there's like you know in
india there's just like less care taken
on this kind of you know data management
um so
that's definitely one of the issues of
course that you know
the other the other issue is that
there's a lot of data now available that
chosen just do no-till
it's not necessarily the best treatment
no-till plus residue right it's the best
treatment but are you in these
experiments are they
they leaving accurate residue or like
patting residue
um you know this is another you know
it's a lot more complex than
i'm sure you're not adding residue and
so the amount of residue depends on the
height they cover
right the previous problems
um
just just and then of course there's an
economic aspect um things like the
amount of fuel you use um uh
how much
traffic wear and tear there's so many
other things right no
social economics is obviously huge from
labor to the mechanization that you have
available
so
there's clearly no easy answers and
one of the things that i'd hoped to do
as part of the project when i initially
suggested this was look more
you know on like the on-farm system look
at these nutrient flows trying to get at
you know
how is carbon and nitrogen and other
nutrients flowing are we adding residue
how much like get more into like dig
into some of those details but the
pandemic prevented that so
yeah um looking at the data that we have
it's really hard to tell like i mean it
does appear that residue and tillage
together um are increasing soil health
because they're affecting different
properties is what it appears from
the
data that i have
but getting into those details of
exactly how residue is managed yeah just
one last thing one of the most common
practices for farmers and essentially
doing some work surveying farmers is
that they
either remove the residues for the
animals right um they do that when they
harvest right depends whether they
combine harvests or hand marks right a
lot of farmers will burn the risk yes
that's one of the major issues yeah that
you have to take into account
right that's not a good practice no and
that's a huge environmental impact so
one of the things like even if we're not
seeing
you know necessarily an increase in
yield there are environmental benefits
beyond just um soil or the yield that
can you know obviously uh be affected by
residue addition so
uh definitely
thank you
yeah thank you very much caviar great
job um i was wondering uh so you saw
sometimes you saw a correlation with
with yield sometimes you didn't with the
soil health insurance
um i remember when maria ganette
did a soul health test and she found
even it was a negative correlation so a
greater yield had lower soil health
i was wondering whether there is an
opportunity for you to
to ask a different question um not the
question does the soil health test
correlate with prop yield but
what would i need to change in the soil
health test so it does you you make some
assumption and you set that up early
that now the ph is optimum in the middle
but for rice that might be right yeah
that was more for like when explaining
yeah um and uh
and there might be other things um uh
and
these
this solar health test was especially
trained
here in in the us right so how about
changing the question around and and
seeing what would you need to tweak
in the soil health test so that you that
it reflects
um a
a good correlation and then and then
conclude something out of it and saying
okay um in these soils with that problem
maybe this parameter
or that weighting factor you're making
also judgments about weighting right
and that might be wrong
uh
yeah uh so in this i should say that the
when i was developing the health index
none of the indicators are weighted so
they're all an equal weight um one of
the things that i'm working on is trying
to see you know what is the best
prediction of the indicators i have for
yields that's kind of getting somewhere
that question of like what is that one
indicator that really
actually reflects that is reflected in
the yield
um
the other thing
i should also mention again when i
talking about the chemical indicators
those have already been uh adjusted for
um from the like
analyses that we do in the u.s so one of
the first things
when we were talking to professors in
the area was you know what are the
concerns
what are the tests that you do here
that you know are actually relevant to
the soils within the state so for some
of the micronutrients like zinc isn't
necessarily mentioned like always
analyzed in the u.s but it is very
importantly born and zinc to the indian
soils so for the chemical indicators
there's already a lot of knowledge there
so we're already able to adjust the cash
for that
for the biological and physical
properties there's not been a lot of you
know work done in that area so
that's yeah one of the issues obviously
like were i kind of transfer that over
but doing more work in the area might
actually be like oh this indicator would
actually work a lot better in india
um and that's something just you know
for the scope of this we're like okay
you know we don't have any of the
institutional knowledge in these areas
so we're kind of just going to translate
what we have there yeah but you could
you have a lot of data so yeah you could
ask that question no definitely
an interesting dimension of this is
is that with the rice wheat system
you're growing two grasses basically
but under very different conditions so
the
the the wheat being grown in the dry
season so some of the physical
properties like aggregate stability that
defines rooting available alcoholic
capacity
they are more important than the dry
season well in the wet season when you
grow rice you have very soft soil uh
the whole system is very different even
though you're actually growing somewhat
similar crops you know yeah and so
uh so you almost have to have a soil
health set of soil health indicators for
rice and a different one for wheat but
yeah
but it's an interesting point i think
we're sort of at a point where because
the cache test is very established and
we
you know have a huge database but it's
sort of time to look at the cache 2.0
you know and then sort of take it up to
the next level now and one of the things
that i was definitely interested in is
like looking at that temporally like if
we take you know samples across so
season's exactly what we might find
those differences um you know physical
properties being more
uh strong or strongly affected in the
dry season versus wet season but again
you know just in terms of scope
that's a completely different set of
chapters that i would have had to do so
future research because in that chapter
i just want to say javier that your
third chapter actually does this right
right and the large and observational
data because it's not just using an
aggregate indices for prediction but
actual
different properties right
if these properties converge and telling
the story about how yield outputs or
diverge or there's no story at all so
yeah hopefully we will start getting
those we'll get some insights yeah
yeah
do we want to see if there's anyone yeah
i think there are a couple of uh
questions on zoom
uh
hey uh
kavia yeah i yeah sorry uh i have been
monitoring the zoom chat i didn't find
any questions yet but i myself have a
question exactly absolutely yeah so
maybe you have covered that a little bit
unfortunately i missed so you showed the
no significant relationships between
the uh
the
your indicators with the
uh
uh with the yield right in that's
chapter two or one i forgot
yeah so i wonder because there's just so
many other factors right to influence
their correlations did you do partial
correlation or did you do any kind of
normalization to tease out the impact
from other factors
so what i presented no that was just
like a very simple regression uh there's
been no further analysis on that
what i want to do and this is kind of
what i was talking about earlier
for the second chapter obviously we're
looking at a whole lot of different
crops that's you can't exactly look at
just oil health versus crops but what
i'm trying to get at is how much you
know biomass is put back into the soil
and kind of think if that's what's
having the effect on soil health so
i'm going to get a little more into some
analysis like you're talking about
as i'm doing this
okay but this is a very simple it's not
taking into effect account any other
factors okay yeah i would recommend
using some kind of causal uh inference
framework to really instead only looking
at the correlation but also looking at
what are the causes and uh
yeah there are some um
uh
recently there are some algorithms
developed to um looking at the the
causal effect which you may want to
consider in your future work just uh
just a suggestion yeah i know that'll be
good especially as i'm getting into like
the last chapter yeah um yeah that would
be interesting to see thank you yeah
anybody else online
uh i don't think so
any
anyone online who would like to ask
questions to kavya
you can simply raise your hand or post
your question to the chat window then i
can read the question to the audience in
the
in the seminar room
i'm not saying anything yeah
no i didn't say anything sorry
i have a more of an observation than a
question so there is a question
this is sort of ripping off of what
you're honest
but uh the idea of catching points
in a sense we already do that with
nutrient analysis because with nutrient
analysis we're figuring out what's there
but then we apply it to a crop
in a sense with the cache system we're
applying it to three crops corn wheat
and soybeans
because those are
our major field problems
but i'm wondering one of the if
part of the results that you're seeing
and this is
good it for india or whatever i'm
wondering if you're seeing better
results
with the cash results because cash is
set up for wheat and corn
versus
rice
you know if we go to cash 2.0 right
you know or expanding whenever the
process isn't better though in a sense
we're looking up the crops themselves
like we're doing nutrient management
versus sort of a universal soil health
you know
yeah
so i mean just being correct if i'm
wrong but since a lot of the data that's
used has been mostly
in the u.s with corn um
that's yeah that's where this has been
fine-tuned for many years but
it has been used in a couple of
different countries from kenya to
colombia from everything from coffee to
obviously rice here
yeah fine-tuning that is kind of
the way i think the approaches we've
taken has been like you know doing it
regionally
but doing it by crop is kind of an
interest or like you know a combination
of crop and soil could be
something to look into
for example we're working with uh
orchard growers
right now
so so perennial
tree crops or vineyards or whatever you
know so you sort of have different
priorities uh different impacts
but yeah there's there's a lot of
potential to make this all better i
think we're sort of in the phase of you
know really
characterizing and quantifying and
interpreting and and then you have an
opportunity to take it to the next level
and it's not only our work it's you know
so health institute did a very extensive
survey of long-term trials here in the
in north america
so we're now getting a much better
picture
up here one more yeah just one quick
thing on this residue again
you started off by talking about an
experiment where they incorporated
residues right
so there's no no till
right no it's tillage it's all filled
yeah and that's how people have been
doing these things
in fact that's like very intensely
tilled there's a plow pan at 15 that you
cannot get below they want to get rid of
the residues so often they burn them and
they plow them and stuff but in no till
one of the interesting things would be
to compare that where you're actually
incorporating the residues where you're
leaving the residues on the surface
right because then the the surface the
ray the the area where the roots are
growing uh is so
different and may have different
properties in terms of soil health than
if you incorporate it right so the
second
or third the third experiment i
presented has you know no till with
residue uh not incorporated uh
on the surface
the problem is there's so much other
management differences um between the
experiments that it's very hard to
compare like you know experiment one to
experiment three
um but that would be really interesting
to see yeah because it's like within an
experiment we could have both treatments
and then the other thing is it probably
takes it it probably takes 10 years just
before you start seeing these different
i mean that's the big reason i wanted to
look at some of these long-term
trials or a
they don't know how to do no till they
don't have the equipment but there's of
course four plants and they plant at the
wrong time and so you have all these
problems with notes
at the beginning i spent 20 years of
fighting this and saying hey come on but
i'm seeing a i keep a
website on conservation
i'm seeing a huge number of papers
coming out now
uh from india yeah on uh on using
no-till with residue
right
15 papers
a month but i've got about 3 000 papers
in the database
you might want to attack that yeah
for sure you can really see
the
disadvantages and advantages of doing
kind of system-based trials right where
you compare different systems versus
more
controlled factorial trials where you
can tease out the effects of residue the
effects of the effect of you know
different crops and so a lot of these
trials are or more systems and then you
run into this problem so yeah this
system works better than that but why is
it is it because of residual work
so
yeah and that's just the way these were
designed
okay well let's wrap it up
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu